hey everybody what's up you guys have
been requesting new spider-man
homecoming so today we're going to talk
all about the vulture he's one of the
coolest members of the sinister six
Michael Keaton is going to be badass so
if you're new to the channel I'm going
to be doing a whole bunch of spider-man
videos this year both for the comics
both for the movies the TV shows there's
even a new spider-man TV show that's
coming up so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and there's a giveaway going
on that I'll explain at the end of the
video so here's ten really cool things
you need to know about the vulture
number ten Michael Keaton is most known
for his role as Batman it's something
that's followed him around his entire
career he said many times since he's
come back to acting he took a break to
raise his family but has come back with
a vengeance
and is always happy to joke about his
time as Batman dagger jackass do look at
yourself in the mirror and say I'm
Batman
17 18 times a day
I'm Batman in fact the reason he said he
left the franchise is because he got a
whiff of Joel Schumacher's Batman why
does Batman always have to be so serious
he literally heard them say that instead
of that was the cue for him to leave so
goodbye Batman number nine enter the
Birdman in 2014 Keaton also starred in
the movie called Birdman which won
several Oscars Keene himself was
nominated for Best Actor it was an
amazing movie but a lot of you might
think this is a funny coincidence
because he's trading one bird costume
for another but it goes way deeper than
that the movie itself is a dark comedy
about the blurring of the characters
personal and professional lives he's
this old washed-up actor who used to be
incredibly famous for playing a
superhero called Birdman starting to
sound familiar right the filmmakers
turned it into a parody of the Batman
franchise and of course Keaton being a
total champ was more than happy to
oblige in order to show how the
character couldn't always tell what was
real from what was fake sometimes his
Birdman self would appear to him behind
and fly around speaking to him in a
really crazy superhero voice is super
trippy
the Birdman voice the Keaton used when
he was in the costume flying around was
the same Batman voice that he used
during the Tim Burton film he says that
it was a big joke between him and the
director he was like yeah go for it use
the Batman voice and of course Keaton
was totally happy to do it
number 8 origins vulture is one of
spider-man's oldest villains in the
comics spider-man debuted an amazing
fantasy number 15 in 1962 vulture
debuted in spider-man's four solo title
amazing spider-man number two in 1963
that next year one of the very first big
villains the basic setup is that you
don't know much about his backstory he
just started out as a villain for
spider-man to defeat he's been
terrorizing New York City with this
artificial harness looking like a
vulture
so Peter Parker decides to photograph
the criminal in action selling the
photographs will help pay for Aunt May
make ends meet so he's got his big break
spider-man tracks vulture to his hideout
before he's doing
a big jewel robbery but ends up getting
his ass handed to him
so he hobbles home and fixes his gear
makes his gadgets a little bit better
goes back and is finally able to take
him down does that not look like
something that happens during this
trailer they're here at Coney Island
spider-man is in his old costume he got
his ass handed to him and then later in
the film we see him saving that Staten
Island Ferry with the new stark tech
suit seven tragic origins like a lot of
villains he starts out as a relatively
good person who falls on hard times he's
an electrician and engineer working with
his partner at BNT electronics best men
in tombs best men steals his money cuts
him out of the business
so tooms is forced to turn to a life of
crime to support himself it was a bit of
a long haul before they paid that off
because Stanley wrote that original
story about him just being a random
spider-man villain with wings on it was
1983 before they called back to him
getting revenge on that partner best
meant for investment in tombs
electronics number six what a
coincidence
he was a founding member of the sinister
six an amazing spider-man annual number
one in 1964 Doctor Octopus breaks out of
prison and gathers Mysterio electro
Kraven the hunter vulture and Sandman to
get revenge against spider-man teaming
up to form the sinister six spider-man
has lost his powers so he's trying to
hide out and lay low till he can regain
his identity what ends up happening is
that he fights each of the members of
the sinister six one at a time through
different facilities what a coincidence
the first fight that he has is at a
Stark Industries power plant
he faces electro what a coincidence that
Iron Man is in this movie there's going
to be a lot of stark tech things he even
offers to help spider-man in the comic
book issue
he fights Kraven in Central Park who has
three Tigers he has to take down he's
offered help by the Human Torch you can
see there's a theme here where he needs
a bunch of his friends along the way and
he says no I'm going to do this by
myself it's my chance to be a hero also
in keeping with the tone of the
spider-man homecoming trailer so this
all comes back around
but he bites Mysterio he bites Sandman
he bites vulture working his way at the
boss letter to dr. octopus number five
vulture can be super creepy when he
wants to be if he doesn't already look
creepy
during superior spider-man spider-man
tracks him down and thinks that he might
be using midgets to commit crimes this
is a Doctor Octopus version of
spider-man when he was in control of
spider-man's body so he's already
horrified by this Doctor Octopus is
horrified by something that the vulture
is doing but then he realizes it's even
worse the vulture has been using small
children to commit crimes something the
other members of the sinister snakes
would never stoop to so if the sinister
six things that you are creepy you're
probably pretty creepy number four civil
war call back from the comics even
though the movie Civil War was different
from comic book civil war
vulture actually got to work for the
government doing something good by
bringing in the criminal spider-man
after he rebelled against Ironman
Ironman took the side of the government
spider-man took Captain America's side
he switched sides during the middle of
the conflict even though it wasn't that
way in the movie so the vulture was
hired to bring spider-man in so even
though he's still relatively evil Dark
Reign style he got to pretend or
make-believe that he was good number
three there have been five different
versions of the vulture in the comics
even though the movie version is going
to be Adrian Toomes the original there
was Blackie Drago clipton Shalit bull
Koreans and then Jimmy de taille so
Blackie Drago was - cellmate in prison
he tried to trick him into giving him
the harness but eventually Toombs got
out of prison and retook the mantle then
later another scientist named Clifton
Shalit mutated into an actual vulture
but actually had real wings so it was a
little more like ultimate spider-man
with a more freakish looking Green
Goblin situation the other latest one
back in 2009 Jimmy khatallah which is
this low-level mobster who was also
mutated into this freakish looking
actual vulture creature so tooms was the
only one that wore the harness the
others were actually mutated into real
vultures number two he went full-on
vampire for a
while he actually got this serum in 1994
during amazing spider-man number 386
called juvenile you can imagine what
that does that allowed him to drain the
life force from living beings when he
touched them with these special
gauntlets so it's basically like a
version of Dracula flying around in the
vulture harness so you can imagine him
draining spider-man's life force they
actually did this a little bit during
spider-man the animated series in the
90s but eventually the effects wore off
and he becomes an old man again in
number one this is not their first
attempt to put Bulger in a spider-man
movie this is the fourth time they try
to get him in and obviously the only
time that it's stuck you would have
remembered if they put him in a previous
movie the first time they tried to get
him in a spider-man movie was during
spider-man 3 Sam Raimi's last movie the
studio decided to switch him out for
venom at the last minute so if you
thought that movie was over stuff with
villains and you didn't like that
portrayal of venom that could have been
the vulture but I don't know if that
would have been any better or not the
second time they try to do vulture was
in the fourth spider-man movie that Sam
Raimi was originally going to do before
he left the franchise the third time was
when they did the amazing spider-man
reboot they were getting ready to ramp
up to sinister six
you saw the vulture harness in the
background sort of an easter egg he was
going to appear in the sony sinister six
movie which kind of went by the wayside
they're still making it eventually but
is there just now rolling out the brand
new spider-man don't expect to see it
anytime soon but of course Sony is
aggressively moving on spider-man IP so
they will try to make a sinister six
movie once they develop all these brand
new characters in homecoming what's
going to happen next is I have some new
flash to post there's some new Wonder
Woman Aries you guys have been asking me
for so I'll get that out as fast as
possible but there is a new round of the
spider-man giveaway I'm actually giving
away copies of the Doctor Strange DVD so
it should be Doctor Strange but all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner kenjutsu kheh please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for that you can click here for
my non-spoilery Logan review and you can
click here for my Black Panther video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five
see you in the next video